[Music]
hello everybody
we are at a spot that you're never going
to believe this is a very very unique
place
welcome to the garage chess club under
the gari art flyover now here's a fun
fact for you the chess actually came
here before the flyover dead in the mid
eighties this was a spot where passerby
would stop by for a game of chess after
a long day at work sip over a cup of tea
and enjoy the evening with friends as
time went on the members the players
crew the people kept it alive by
bringing in stools and chairs to play a
game of chess on today and on any given
day you find a mix of people here from
students to shopkeepers the local
residents to city dwellers just
completely oblivious to the crazy sound
all around them in one of the busiest
intersections of Calcutta completely
immersed and enjoying the game of chess
sometimes you've even got local
grandmasters and masters visiting this
very special place and today it's five
times us champion Hikaru Nakamura and
world number 3 ding leerin who decided
to challenge the local
[Music]
and what an incredible day that was in
this super unique chess club the Gaga
has chess club under one of the noisiest
craziest flyovers I have ever seen in my
life now this is a city that truly loves
sports
you